[Music]
foreign ly inaugurated Arkansas governor
rising star in the Republican party no
stranger to this audience Sarah Huckabee
Sanders delivered an incredibly powerful
what do you think do you like it okay
and passionate response to President
Biden's disaster State of the Union
Tuesday night let's take a look at some
of the highlights take a look
let us reaffirm our commitment to a
Timeless American idea
that government exists not to rule the
people
but to serve the people I'm the first
woman to lead my state
and he's the first man to surrender his
presidency to awoke mob that can't even
tell you what a woman is the dividing
line in America is no longer between
bride or left
the choice
is between normal
crazy it's time for a new generation of
Republican leadership Republicans
believe in an America where strong
families thrive in safe communities
where jobs are abundant and paychecks
are rising
where the freedom our veterans shed
their blood to defend is the birthright
of every man woman and child
give a warm welcome to Governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders Governor great to have
you
thank you for being here thank you
um
I wrote you and I was on the air after
the state of the union and I said you
were the star of the night and it wasn't
even close and under those circumstances
number one Biden as the bully pulpit of
the presidency he's got 535 psycho
lunatics that are clapping every other
word at least half the crowd is clapping
and and anyway and I thought about it
and there you are in a room and and you
are telling truth like it's it's either
normal or crazy like everyone in this
audience so far is normal you know
everybody outside in New York is crazy
um but this is really what it's about
it's the the Democratic party is nothing
like the old Democratic party is that a
fair statement
absolutely I think that any person who's
paying attention can see the absolute
shift that the Democrat Party has made
so far to the left that there's no other
way to describe it other than crazy the
things that they are pushing whether
it's you know outlawing gas stoves or
defining genders by the second uh
everything that they come up with is
just moving so far out of the mainstream
that there's no other way to describe it
you know I was thankful that I got to
follow President Biden because he does
help set the bar a little bit low and
that made my job a bit easier the other
part he just has a terrible story to
tell he has been an absolute failure
over the last two years in anybody that
is paying attention in this country sees
those failures every single day when
they go to the gas pump when they go to
the grocery store they are feeling the
breakdown of this presidency and so I it
was an absolute honor an incredible
opportunity and I'm thankful to speaker
McCarthy and leader McConnell for giving
me the chance to tell our side of the
story and hopefully share the optimistic
View and the belief that we have with
the Republican Party you've signed 17
bills into law you've only been there a
month you have probably one of the most
comprehensive education bills in the
country that you're advancing right now
including going from 48th and teacher
pay to fourth in the U.S you rescinded
all these covet executive orders that's
a lot to accomplish in 31 days what else
is on the agenda
we we did not run and and spend two
years on the campaign Trail to take it
easy so we've got our foot on the gas
and we're not taking it off anytime soon
I'm proud of the fact that we got rid of
some of the covid mandates that were
totally outdated it's time for not just
our state but frankly the country to
move on and move forward we have banned
things like CRT latinx in our state
government and yesterday had the
opportunity to launch the most
comprehensive conservative education
reform anywhere in the country I'm
extremely excited about the fact that we
are going to move Arkansas to the top
and set the standard for what it can
look like across the country all right
uh let me ask you about this so radical
left-wing socialists you know more on
and out in California the governor Gavin
Newsom he wasted no time going after you
Governor Sanders as you probably know
and he sent out this tweet attacking you
for Arkansas's murder rate uh seemingly
ignoring the fact that you have been in
office I think as of today a whopping 31
days
by comparison when you look at Gavin
newsom's time in public office his time
as San Francisco mayor lieutenant
governor now Governor Newsome has spent
nearly 7 000 days driving California
straight into the ground crime and
homelessness and now through the roof
the drug problem in California out of
control reports of school children being
forced to walk through open-air drug
dens California ranked dead last again
in the U-Haul index Gavin you are
literally chasing people out of your
state every day nearly a thousand people
a day about 300 000 a year so Gavin I
think you ought to be fixing and focused
on fixing your disaster that you created
instead of lecturing a new governor that
has accomplished more in 31 days than
you did in seven thousand uh do you have
any reaction to your friend Gavin
you know I learned a long time ago Sean
if the left is attacking you you're
probably doing something right and so I
think it only further validates the
actions that we've taken over the last
31 days that we are doing things the
right way I'm proud of the things that
are taking place here in our state let's
not forget he literally had to run ads
begging people to stay in California not
that long ago and every single town I go
to in Arkansas I meet someone who has
moved from California my message to them
is we're glad you're here but don't
forget why you left California we are
proud of our state you're welcome to
come gates are open for people to come
but leave your stupid politics behind
that that's got to be the motto uh
Governor great to see you
congratulations that was a great speech
we appreciate you being with us all
right and thank you and coming up
Bible's age becoming an issue he says no
but we've got tape that says otherwise
the Biden blunder is coming up low
lights we'll check in with Jimmy phela
Joe Contra David McDowell they're coming
up straight ahead as we continue